WERE GOING TO HAVE TO BE LOOKING
AT THIS ACROSS THE BOARD.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE MASSACRE
IN TEXAS, PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
TURNING HIS ATTENTION TO THE
SO-CALLED GUN LOBBY.
AND EARLIER TODAY, SAYS THIS
ABOUT THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
WATCH.
>> YOU MUST ASK, WHEN IN GOD'S
NAME WILL WE DO WITH NEEDS TO BE
DONE DO NOT COMPLETELY STOP TO
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE AMOUNT
OF CARNAGE THAT GOES ON IN THIS
COUNTRY.
SECOND AMENDMENT IS NOT
ABSOLUTE.
THE IDEA THAT AN 18-YEAR-OLD CAN
WALK INTO A STORE AND BUY
WEAPONS OF WAR DESIGNED AND
MARKETED TO KILL.
I THINK IT'S JUST WRONG.
IT JUST VIOLATES COMMON SENSE.
>> ON SUNDAY, THE PRESIDENT AND
FIRST LADY WILL TRAVEL TO TEXAS
TO MEET WITH THE FAMILIES OF THE
VICTIMS AND MEANWHILE, OVER IN
WASHINGTON, FAR LEFT DEMOCRATS
ARE INTENSIFYING THEIR CALLS FOR
MORE FIREARM RESTRICTIONS LIKE
MASSACHUSETTS SENATOR ED MARKEY
WHO SAYS IT'S TIME TO PACK THE
SUPREME COURT TO MAKE SURE THAT
GUN CONTROL LAWS AREN'T STRUCK
DOWN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE TO TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY THE THREAT IN WHICH AN
ILLEGITIMATE FAR RIGHT
SUPREME COURT POSES TO GUN
SAFETY IN OUR COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO EXPAND THE
SUPREME COURT TO GET BACK THE
TWO STOLEN SEATS THAT THE
REPUBLICANS AND DONALD TRUMP IT
TOOK FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SO
THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT WHEN WE
PUT GUN SAFETY LAWS ON THE
BOOKS, THEY ARE NOT OVERWRITTEN
BY THE SUPREME COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> EARLIER TONIGHT AT THE NRA
CONVENTION IN HOUSTON, THE 45TH
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP WARNED
AGAINST DISARMING LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS AND LAID OUT HIS PLAN
FOR SCHOOL SAFETY.
HERE IT IS.
>> AND JOE BIDEN BLAMED FOR THE
GUN LOBBY, HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
AMERICANS LIKE YOU.
AND ALONG WITH DEMOCRATS THIS
WEEK, HE WAS SHAMEFULLY
SUGGESTING THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
SOMEHOW OKAY WITH LETTING SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS HAVE BEEN.
THEY ARE NOT OKAY WITH IT.
THIS RHETORIC IS HIGHLY DIVISIVE
AND DANGEROUS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, IT'S WRONG.
IT HAS NO PLACE IN OUR POLITICS.
>> WHAT WE NEED NOW IS A TOP TO
BOTTOM SECURITY OVERHAUL AT
SCHOOLS ALL ACROSS OUR COUNTRY.
[APPLAUSE]
EVERY BUILDING SHOULD HAVE A
SINGLE POINT OF ENTRY.
THERE SHOULD BE STRONG INTERIOR
FENCING, METAL DETECTORS, AND
THE USE OF NEW TECHNOLOGY TO
MAKE SURE THAT NO UNAUTHORIZED
INDIVIDUAL COULD EVER ENTER THE
SCHOOL WITH A WEAPON.
SPEAK ALL RIGHT, HERE FOR
REACTION, REPUBLIC SENATE CAN DO
MY CANDIDATE ADAM LAXALT ALONG
WITH ARIZONA SENATE CANDIDATE
WHO IS THE CURRENT
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
GRAND CANYON STATE.
GENTLEMEN COME AT THE WELCOME
ABOARD.
LET ME START WITH YOU, ADAM, IF
I COULD.
WE SEE PEOPLE COMPLAINED THAT
THESE THINGS KEEP HAPPENING,
THERE'S NEVER ANY CHANGE.
PART OF IT IS BECAUSE OF ALL
THIS POLITICAL RHETORIC SUCKING
ALL THE AIR OUT OF THE ROOM.
NOBODY GETS TO THE MORE BORING
SOLUTIONS LIKE SCHOOL SAFETY,
DOORS, HARDENING THOSE TARGETS.
AND YOU CAN'T RAISE MONEY ON
THAT NECESSARILY.
SO WE GO FROM ONE TO THE OTHER
WITH THESE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
IN WASHINGTON FOR 50 YEARS AND
THEN THEY STILL COMPLAIN ABOUT
IT.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS PLAYING OUT
WHEN EVERYONE STILL RETURNS TO
LEGISLATION, POLITICS, BLAMING,
ET CETERA.
>> PEOPLE WANT LEADERSHIP.
AND FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN TO RUSH
TO THE CAMERAS THAT NIGHT
WITHOUT THE FULL INFORMATION AND
ONCE AGAIN BLAME 100 MILLION LAW
ABIDING GUN OWNERS IS AN
ABSOLUTE DISGRACE.
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW WHY WE CAN'T
FIX THESE THINGS, BECAUSE
WASHINGTON TROTS OUT THESE SAME
ATTACKS OVER AND OVER.
WE LOOKED AT THIS WHEN I WAS
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WE MET WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THE EXACT SAME SOLUTIONS YOU
ARE HEARING TODAY, WE PROPOSED A
FEW YEARS AGO.
EVERY TIME YOU SEE A BREAKDOWN
OF COMMUNICATION YOU USUALLY SEE
THAT THE SCHOOL AND THE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT DID NOT HAVE
PROPER TRAINING.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A SHOOTER
RESPONSE.
YOU DON'T HAVE SINGLE ENTRANCE,
AND YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE CLASSROOM DOORS ACTUALLY
CLOSE.
WE HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR ARMED
GUARDS IN SCHOOLS FOR A VERY
LONG TIME.
IT IS DEMOCRATS THAT REFUSED TO
ALLOW THAT.
THIS IS A TIRED TO DEAL AND I
HOPE THAT AMERICANS WILL REJECT
THIS.
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT GOING TO
PROTECT OUR KIDS.
WE NEED REAL SOLUTIONS AND WE
NEED THEM NOW.
>> IT IS UNDERSTANDABLE, MARK.
UNDERSTANDABLY EMOTIONAL.
WE UNDERSTANDABLY WANT TO MAJOR
SOLUTIONS.
WE WANT THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
AND YET WE DO NOTICE THAT IT IS
ALMOST AS THOUGH SOME PROBLEMS
THE POLITICIANS DON'T WANT TO
HAVE GO AWAY.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE CAN HAVE
THESE IDEAS, BUT THEY ALSO HAVE
TO BE IMPLEMENTED.
YOU CAN THROW MONEY AT A
PROBLEM, HAVE THESE STRATEGIES,
BUT IF PEOPLE DON'T IMPLEMENT
THEM PROPERLY, WE HAVE AN ISSUE.
AND WITH THAT MAN THAT RAN FROM
THE BARBERS IN ORDER TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE -- THOSE WOULD BE THE
GUNS THAT WOULD BE GONE.
WE WOULD BE RELYING ON JUST THE
POLICE AND WE'VE SEEN IN THIS
PARTICULAR INSTANCE WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU ARE RELYING JUST ON THE
POLICE WITH FIREARMS.
>> ALL OF OUR HEARTS BROKE WHEN
WE SAW THE STORY.
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN PRAYING FOR
COMFORT FOR THE FAMILIES AND
PRAYING FOR PEACE IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND WORLD.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS WE ARE
NOT TALKING ENOUGH ABOUT IS WHAT
HAS HAPPENED IN THIS COUNTRY AND
THE LAST 30 YEARS THAT THIS
EVILNESS THAT IS PERPETUATED TO
YOUNGER AND YOUNGER KIDS AND
WHETHER IT'S THE EFFECT OF THE
MEDIA, VIDEO GAMES.
IT'S HAVING AN IMPACT.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY, THE
POTTED ADMINISTRATION, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO
POLITICIZE THIS ISSUE.
BUT IF MORE GUN LAWS WORK,
CHICAGO WOULD BE THE SAFEST CITY
IN AMERICA.
WE KNOW THERE ARE PLACES LIKE
YOUR PREVIOUS GUESS WAS TALKING
ABOUT IN ISRAEL.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE MEMBERS
OF THAT COMMUNITY ARE ARMED
BECAUSE OF THE WARRIOR OF
TERRORISTS ATTACKED.
THEY HARDEN TARGETS AND WE KNOW
HERE IN AMERICA, WE GUARD OUR
BANKS.
WITH ARMED SECURITY.
AND YET, WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
ARM THE MOST PRECIOUS RESOURCE,
OUR CHILDREN?
THAT'S WHY LOCAL COMMUNITIES
NEED TO COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS
MAKING SURE DOORS ARE LOCKED.
MAKING SURE WE HAVE THE PROPER
SECURITY INCLUDING POLICE
OFFICERS.
>> IT'S INTEREST INCOME A LOT OF
PEOPLE DID PULL OUT OF THE NRA
CONFERENCE.
AND THERE'S A THING CALLED
PROJECTED IDENTITY.
WHERE ONE SIDE PROJECTS -- WE
KNOW ABOUT PROJECTION IN
GENERAL, BUT PROJECTS AN
ACCUSATION ABOUT WHO SOMEONE
ELSE IS AND IF YOU HEAR IT
ENOUGH, ELSE ADOPTS THE FALLS
PROJECTED IDENTITY -- AND I SEE
CONSERVATIVES DOING THIS ON
ISSUES OF MORALITY ON ISSUES OF
WHO THEY ARE AND WHAT MATTERS,
IF YOU HEAR YOU ARE RACIST LONG
ENOUGH, MAYBE WILL BEGIN BEGIN
TO BELIEVE IT.
PEOPLE PULLED OUT OF THE NRA
CONVENTION, WHEN ITS AMERICAN
CITIZENS THAT ARE MEMBERS.
AND IT IS A CONTINUAL KIND OF
LIBELING OF THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
CITIZEN WHEN THIS IS EXACTLY
WHERE WE GO EACH TIME.
>> THIS IS A TIME FOR COURAGE,
NOT A TIME TO BACK DOWN WHEN THE
MEDIA, WHEN THE DEMOCRATS, WHEN
HOLLYWOOD, WHEN PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS FRANCHISES -- WHEN THEY
GO ILL AND ON SOMETHING, YOU
BETTER BELIEVE THEY ARE WRONG ON
THE ISSUE.
OUR VOTERS AND AMERICANS WANT US
TO STAND UP FOR THEM.
THEY ARE THE VOICELESS.
WE WENT THROUGH THIS WITH BLM
TOO.
AS A FORMER TOP COP TO WATCH
REPUBLICANS NOT STAND UP AGAINST
THE BLM RIOTS, DID NOT STAND UP
AND DEFEND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT TOOK WEEKS BEFORE THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS SAFE ENOUGH TO GO
OUT AND DEFEND THESE
INSTITUTIONS.
WE NEED PEOPLE OUT THERE TODAY,
RIGHT NOW.
AND THOSE WHO DID SPEAK TODAY
LIKE SENATOR CRUZ AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP, GOD BLESS THEM.
IT IS THE LAW ABIDING CITIZEN
THAT DESERVED TO BE RESPECTED,
THEY DESERVE TO BE SPOKEN FOR,
AND GUESS WHAT?
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS, A LOT
MORE PEOPLE HAVE UNDERSTOOD THAT
IT SPOKE TO HOODS IS PARAMOUNT
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND WE NEED
MORE DEFENSE FOR SCHOOLS, NOT
LESS.
>> LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE POLICE
CLEARLY HAVE BEEN UNDER FIRE,
HAVE BEEN DENIGRATED.
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND HOW THAT'S
DEPRESSING, HAS AN IMPACT ON
THEIR SENSE OF SELF AND ALSO THE
DESIRE TO BECOME
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ALL OF THIS HAS TO CHANGE.
AND THEY WANT TO TAKE FIREARMS
AWAY FROM LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS.
EVERYTHING THE